hi I'm Erik Bosse and we now have a
trailer for fantastic beasts the crimes
of Grindelwald that is packed with
interesting miserable details connecting
to the Harry Potter books and films
specifically some clues hinting at the
deathly hallows that's right we're nerds
for everything else here at new
rockstars so of course Harry Potter's on
the list what do you think we got that
lightning bolt what you need my
potterhead creds fine
I was sorted into ravenclaw in
thunderbird my Patronus my italian wand
rowan wood wood dragon heartstring core
13 inches and slightly springy
flexibility but we'll save him for bus
after dark sorry let's break down
everything you missed in this trailer
shot-by-shot and yeah spoiler warning in
case any my theories end up being right
cool
rebellion
[Music]
okay right off the bat in case the first
fantastic beasts didn't feel hairy
pottery enough for you Byam Hogwarts
castle this imagery has really become
the primary welcome-home symbol for
Harry Potter fans kind of like what the
Cinderella Castle is for Disney and not
coincidentally this magical castle is
also the main visual attraction at both
Wizarding World parks we see a group of
orders from the Ministry of Magic
operating on that bridge leading into
the school grounds and immediately we
core nerds are wondering how is this
possible isn't there supposed to be a
protection spell that blocks people from
operating into Hogwarts yes but it's not
clear if this bridge is within school
grounds technically it was an original
creation for the Deathly Hallows part-2
movie also Albus Dumbledore isn't
Hogwarts headmaster yet so maybe the
current headmaster is allowing those
orders to pass through depending on the
year that headmaster would be either
Armondo Dippet or his predecessor
phineas Nigella's black that's right I
memorized the names of all Hogwarts
Headmaster's but not my sister's
birthday I'm a terrible person
but a great wizard
let's move on I have some questions for
you professor this is a surprise there's
a rumor that Newt Scamander is headed to
Paris okay in this section if you look
closely you can see that among those
ministry or Zara Theseus commander newts
older brother and Lidl estranged newts
past romantic interest who is now
engaged to said brother that's rough you
can actually see Lida levy in the
classroom right as we cut to that shot
Ledo was hinted at in the first
fantastic beasts movie Newt is still in
love with her he kept a framed photo of
her in his work shed it's kind of weird
and hemoptysis my translation of Eddie
redmayne's version of it which sounded
more like understand anything but and
Queenie used legitimacy on him and
observed that Leda was a taker in a
relationship maybe that means Leda letís
was using new to get to his older
handsomer war hero ministry connected
brother
I'm sure this movie will give us a
clearer sense of whatever the drama was
between these two now in this classroom
we see the back of young Albus
Dumbledore more on him in a bit but look
closely at that classroom the skeleton
hanging from the ceiling the staircase
in the back of the other shot you may
recognize it as the defense against the
dark arts classroom from the previous
movies now yes Dumbledore was actually
the transfiguration professor at
Hogwarts before becoming headmaster but
maybe they just moved classrooms around
in this room you can see the
multi-tiered white tower thingy that
actually showed up in Dumbledore's
office when he just headmaster in the
other movies and I'm not totally certain
but that the background might be the
photograph that Lupin used to play music
during the Boggart scene and Prisoner of
Azkaban and we learned that Newt is
headed to Paris in this sequel the
filmmakers confirm that each of these
fantastic beasts movies will take place
in a different major city but I'm
wondering why this postcard was torn up
in the first place look closely there's
definitely writing on the back of it
maybe this was sent to Newt from Leda
and heartbroken he tore it up first
before deciding to give it a second look
move on Newt and yeah lets us move on to
I know he's working under your orbitals
what do you have to say for yourself
Dumbledore okay here there's another
Harry Potter reference with the put
powder aka the deluminator Dumbledore
use one in the very first scene on pivot
drive and a sorcerer's stone or the
philosopher's stone he bequeathed it and
his will to Ron Weasley which we saw in
Deathly Hallows Part 1 remember Ron
later gave that mushy speech about how
it released a tiny ball of light let him
back the area in Hermione
so maybe in this shot this is Dumbledore
and this could be the same deluminator
that was later used by Ron also we get
our first close-up of young Dumbledore
being played in this movie by Jude Law
he comes off as very you and McGregor
obi-wan cool confident just a wisp of
the majestic beard he'll grow later on
and maybe this will also end with a hot
steamy duel between him and his evil
rival and even though a lot of this
movie is set in Paris this scene here
with Newton Dumbledore is set in London
check out that clock tower statues the
architecture that is the rooftop of st.
Paul's Cathedral and let's move on if
you'd ever have the pleasure to teach
him you know newt is not a great
follower of orders
[Music]
the times coming leave okay after the
reverse shot of Dumbledore in the
classroom there's this interesting shot
of Gellert Grindelwald the evil wizard
played by Johnny Depp now where is he
exactly judging from his hair which is
still short and spiky like it was at the
end of the first fantastic beasts I
initially thought Grindelwald was under
trial here following his arrest but this
auditorium seems far more ancient than
the courtrooms we saw in the Ministry of
Magic in order the Phoenix or at the
McCue SAAA and fantastic beasts those
look like old tombs sarcophagi
surrounding them
reminiscent of the ones of the Knights
Templar in Temple Church in London also
take a look at the woman beside him
holding an orb like thing this looks
like vin de rozier a new character in
the movie The Rose ears are a famous
pure blood family whose descendants
later served as Death Eaters under
Voldemort so maybe what we're looking at
here is a gathering of Grindelwald
followers in some ancient burial chamber
for pure blood wizards a gathering of
the blacks and the lestranges and the
Rossiter's just going out on a limb here
maybe this chamber is underneath nerman
guard the fortress Grindelwald built to
imprison his enemies which later
ironically served as the place where he
was imprisoned until his death either
way it's pretty scary that this many
people are drinking the ethnic cleansing
kool-aid but hey it was pre World War
two Europe everybody was doing it
unfortunately let's move on when you
were gonna have to pick a side
[Music]
are you going somewhere no way guys how
I jeez
okay next we see Tina Goldstein the
American or from the first fantastic
beasts
you look closely behind her this statue
is definitely moving maybe this is
taking place in the French Ministry of
Magic whatever it's gonna end up being
called and she's not the only character
coming back everybody is for some reason
Newt is bringing back Jacob Kowalski Dan
Fogler character it was honestly my
favorite character from the first movie
sure he supposedly had his memory wiped
at the end of that movie it's not clear
if he was 100% obliviated he gave
Queenie that odd look of recognition and
his pastries definitely looked very
fantastic
beastly or maybe he's been unobligated
and like Newton is torturing the guy by
taking upon adventures over and over
again and just like magically wiping his
mind and of itemizing him that was it be
more it's the dark place anyway behind
Jacob are two new magical creatures an
owl like bird and another animal with
antlers some are suggesting the bird
could be a flipper which is really fun
to say Wooper but according to
Pottermore flippers are much more
colorful than that now let me know what
you think these things are and then on
this rooftop overlooking the Eiffel
Tower in Paris
there's Creedence bare bones as Roe
Miller's character from the first
fantastic beasts he's releasing his
obscurest curse into the city beside him
is another new character maledictis
played by claudia kemp she suffers from
a blood curse that turns her into a
beast she's one of the acts in the
circus are canis possibly the enchanting
snake girl her wardrobe definitely has a
scaly snakeskin texture let's move on in
the next section
[Music]
okay in this section we get a glimpse of
this movie's amazing set design with
this glass dome interior I think this
could be the French Ministry of Magic
that I referenced earlier check out the
design of the ceiling
words written around the circumference
include names of various magical beasts
dragon limit lap lynnie flue
manipulation II object loving thing that
we saw in the first movie this cinta mid
duck see those are the very things that
showed up in the first fantastic beasts
and a lot of Harry Potter video games
but I and I don't I'm not saying that
right it's a French word for broom and
he will come it's a seahorse but not
like the seahorse that we know the half
horse half fish kind God what a
miserable existence that thing has
anyway all of these are actually the
French wizard names for all the
constellations they have their own
constellations it's awesome
now there's also this cool shot of some
ballet like gala with Lita Lestrange in
attendance the decor reminds me a lot of
the Yule Ball and Goblet of Fire and
maybe this dancer is a graduate of
beauxbatons at school was known for its
grace and it's fine arts now I don't
know if this scenes taking place at
beauxbatons like some of you have said
that Institute isn't in Paris it's
actually located somewhere in the
Pyrenees mountain range between France
and Spain there's also this shot of the
White Cliffs of Dover along England's
south coast facing France now if you
know your history this area served an
important purpose during the Second
World War
maybe this will be another way that
these movies connect to real world
events like the underground Wizarding
war paralleling the human conflicts
leading up to World War two following
this is a quick shot of Newt riding a
sea creature underwater now this looks
kind of like a kelpy which is another
magical beast
this thing could be how Newt crosses the
English Channel in to France and then
there's this very interesting shot and
what looks like an underground train
tunnel somebody Newt
maybe Grindelwald is examining various
markings clearly made by an insane
person
but what are they let's do an enhance on
this if you look closely among these
markings is a wizard family tree showing
a generation of the Lestrange family
close to the top you can see the name
Corvus Lestrange and the face beneath
that name is full white maybe implying
that he's a full-blood wizard beneath
him to the left there's a black on white
face with a female symbol behind it
maybe this person was a
or a muggle-born someone perhaps Corvis
produced a child with leading to this
figure on the bottom left another female
notice a symbol with the name Lita
Lestrange beneath it this face is half
white half black
maybe guys Lita isn't so pure blood
after all maybe I'm just reading it
wrong in these black and white faces
refer to these characters skin colors
which kind of weird thing to start
mattering in the Wizarding World but if
you look at this even more closely
there's an even bigger bombshell here
and I think it might be a kind of big
spoiler so if you don't want to know any
of these big reveals that could come up
in this movie skip to this time okay
let's slide on over to the bottom right
there's another figure with a male
symbol next to it and underneath the
name credence barebone this I don't know
if I'm interpreting this family tree
correctly and again it was scrawled into
a train station wall by a crazy person
Lita in credence are a half-brother and
sister sort of ok there's obviously a
lot of information on this wall so if
you spot anything else let you know in
the comments below we move on to this
shot of circus archanis now arcana's
roughly translates to secret in Latin
and music biz curiosities of advances
lots French bad French in my case for
Museum of living curiosities so I'm
guessing this is a circus freak show
that melodic this is a part of perhaps
she's that snake creature being
advertised over on the left inside it's
really just too crowded to know what is
in the cage but the guy in the red
behind the cage is another new character
that's kinder the circus owner he's
being played by Oliver dari Alison and
we see this new wizard that's Youssef ,
and there's a quick adorable cameo by
baby group I mean a picket the leafy bow
truckle creature returning from the
first movie and then there's a shot here
of credence angrily Breen a bunch of
creatures from a cage and it's cut with
this crazy explosion of an upstairs flat
in Paris if you look closely through all
that splintery debris that kind of looks
like Gellert Grindelwald down there oh
no his destructive power is pretty
severe guys this is not a good time to
be living in the city of love let's move
on
[Music]
I can't move against criminal fault okay
in this section there's a carriage being
drawn by s trolls remember those are the
flying horse like creatures that are
only visible to people who have seen
someone die they pull the carriages and
Hogwarts Harry and his friends later
flew on them in order of the Phoenix and
they showed up in deathly hallows the
building they're diving from is located
in the wall street district of Manhattan
making me think this is some acoustic
carriage transporting the prisoner that
we see in the next shot a gala
Grindelwald man oh man Johnny Depp looks
super creepy I love how one of his
pupils has a white shade to it it's
almost like he's staring in deers oh no
my head Johnny Depp this may be the
sequence of Grindelwald epic escape no
just something tells me these two or
one's it won't be enough to contain it's
also interesting that Dumbledore says
this de Newt here I calmed remove the
game screaming fault it has to be you
now there's a few ways to interpret that
one is that Dumbledore Grenier Walter
just old friends
putting JK rowling may be more than
friends but apparently they won't go
into that in a movie and maybe
Dumbledore just can't bring himself to
hurt him or maybe as an old friend
Grindelwald knows Dumbledore's
weaknesses the other explanation and
this is a theory I'm going with is that
Grindelwald
is the possessor of the Elder Wand
making him invincible in battle and the
reason it has to be Newt that bites him
is at the end of fantastic beasts Newt
was the one to disarm Grindelwald using
one of his creatures to lasso them up
now of course Tino uses Accio to summon
the wand but technically it was Newt who
disarmed him when you disarmed the
possessor of the Elder Wand
you become the new possessor that's how
Harry Potter defeated Voldemort
Dumbledore repossessed the Elder Wand
from Grindelwald after defeating him in
1945 draco disarmed Voldemort atop the
Astronomy tower and later Harry whistled
in' just aren't the one from Draco so
even though Voldemort was holding the
wand when he grave robbed it from
Dumbledore
it's true master was Harry Potter and
Voldemort Skilling curse rebounded
similarly currently the elder ones true
master could be newts even though
Grindelwald is carrying it now since we
already saw that particular version of
events go down in Deathly Hallows part-2
I'd be a little surprised if they just
use the same switcheroo at the end of
of Grindelwald like I could see that
true possessor logic being the reason
newt has to go confront Grindelwald but
hopefully the showdown will go
differently and let's move on to this
last section
[Music]
[Music]
okay this last bit shows us this
commander brothers Newton Theseus
side-by-side in some serious battle and
what looks like a graveyard together
they slam their one than the ground
forming what looks like some kind of
medical barrier perhaps they're
defending the tomb of some ancient
wizard perhaps the resting place of one
of the other two deathly hallows the
cloak of invisibility or the
resurrection stone considering newts the
most famous Hufflepuff it'd be
interesting if this were like the grave
of Helga hufflepuff I'm not Hufflepuff
Ravenclaw speaking of the Deathly
Hallows these final title images snuck
and the Deathly Hallows into the design
first in the smoke the symbol of the
Hallows appears the vertical line for
the Elder Wand the circle for the
resurrection stone the triangle for the
cloak of invisibility and together they
form Grindelwald symbol of all three
Hallows together and if you look closely
the final title of the crimes of
Grindelwald hides all three Deathly
Hallows in plain sight again the eye in
crimes is the Elder Wand the a and
Grindelwald is a cloak and the G of
Grindelwald is a stone and yes it's kind
of hard to notice when you're being
blasted in the ears by John Williams's
Harry potter-themed doing an impression
of the Avengers theme
[Music]
III get it movies everything's epic but
I want to throw it over to you guys with
a question do you need all of the key
characters to come back from the first
fantastic beasts Newt Tina but also
Queenie and Jacob and Creedence or do
you just want to see Dumbledore and
Grindelwald to get it on in battle what
else do you think I'm in comment down
below to let me know your thoughts on
this trailer or tweet me directly Eddie
a vos and follow new rockstars on
Twitter for updates on our videos like
this video and subscribe to new
rockstars for coverage of all the stuff
that you love I've made videos about the
first fantastic beasts but also deep
dives and everything related to Star
Wars or marble Game of Thrones we do it
all here thanks for watching and hey
just to give you a sense of what it's
like to work here at new rock stars
which once you know it is conveniently
right across the street from the
Wizarding World of Harry Potter see it
back there yeah you try working every
day as you look out the window and all
your dreams and delicious butter beer
beckons to you you know what screw it I
quit I'm gonna be a wizard